do you really believe you could beat me
in a straight-up old-fashioned fistfight
let me tell you something me and you
one-on-one no one else around I will
beat your ass like a Cherokee drum maybe
what they will find out oh you better
hope that day never comes
Norma get back yourself system
malfunction just about function away
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
taken it personal you were only supposed
to create a diversion Roman that what
complete destruction what you want from
me I'm Roman tears man it's what I do
great - Hey - what play - bombs away
[Music]
holy
you know what I like about you dawn your
genuine outlook but you're assembling
the hell of a job brother we get back to
the base beers on me about to go up
against the only thing they can't handle
you
did you ever think you'd betray your
family the way you did today Dominic
Toretto
just turned on us oh well well see look
at that I don't know why he's doing this
that wasn't dumb she's a very definition
of high tech terrorism and now she's
working with your guy I think I found my
team this should be interesting
[Music]
want to play like that this is
impossible
which is why they gonna need a little
help I will beat you like a Cherokee
drum we about to go like this
it took longer than I expected if you're
gonna catch dog you guys are gonna work
together surprise just for love I've
been waiting for this we got a tank
let's roll
any kind I don't know the old Dom is in
there I don't give a damn I'm taking you
down so right off this place
my plant is heating up me I don't know
maybe Senor in an orange Lamborghini
can put you know
[Music]
we come on let's go register yeah we are
about to go on
[Music]
Oh see we're gonna need a bigger truck
[Music]
oh you're gonna turn your back on family
you
[Music]
you